let's bring in Virginia Congressman Ben
Klein who is still down in Arizona
Congressman thank you so much for
getting up with us on this Friday
morning so you know the tour was
Wednesday you were there we actually
have video showing you touring at the
border the hearing was last night and I
know there were residents who were
talking to you guys and giving their
first-hand account of what of what
they're dealing with what did they tell
you
well Tom Ashley it's great to be with
you I wish the Democrats on the
Judiciary Committee could have been with
us today because then they would have
seen the impact that these waves of
migrants have had not only on their
Health Care system on the availability
of beds in their hospital but on their
education system on the with the farmers
who we talk to about the impact on their
crops it's bad enough if they knew
what's going on down here but gosh it's
really really bad and they needed to see
it Congressman as we show video of Wendy
Wednesday night's walk through take us
through your experience what did you see
what did you feel
well at the wall you just see huge gaps
and when you think about the fact that
during the last year the Trump
Administration they had 8 000 migrant
encounters during the first year of the
Biden Administration they had a hundred
thousand migrant Encounters in Yuma
sector and this past year they had three
hundred thousand it's it's getting out
of control and the people we talk to are
having their safety their personal
safety impacted their kids education and
lives impacted and it's just really
overflowing across the country so that
every Community is now a border
community
Congressman we see these videos we hear
these first-hand accounts
um of what's going on at the border my
question to you is why couldn't
President Biden have flown down to the
Border he made his way all the way over
to Kiev in Ukraine and he went to Poland
I'm sure the flight would have been much
shorter and a lot cheaper for American
taxpayer dollars to fly down there so my
question how often is the GOP in contact
with the White House saying you guys
really need to get down here we need
help at this border we need funding
listen our doors are open on the house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
and the rest of the committee are ready
to work with this White House to secure
our border to make sure we reform our
Asylum laws to make sure that we restore
title 42 remain in Mexico becomes a
priority and we build the wall and
invest in technology and the other
things that are necessary to secure this
border Congressman pretty shameful that
not one Democrat was there how can
Democrats say they are serious about
border securing the border the Border
crisis at large when they dismiss
Republican efforts their words as a
political stunt
well it's not a stunt you know they talk
about education but let's talk about the
impact of 300 000 migrants on education
down here and education in all of our
schools uh English as a second language
courses hiring teachers let's they talk
about health care well let's talk about
the impact of 300 000 migrants here on
the Health Care System hospitals at risk
all of our hospitals have beds that
could be going to community members
being taken up by illegal immigrants and
costing our hospitals and our taxpayers
money
doesn't change in Yuma especially when
you talk about the hospital and you talk
about Yuma Regional Medical which
walking about for months
20 million dollars in six months I'm
sure that number has gone up because
that was a number we saw over a month
and a half ago what's going to happen to
this hospital if people cannot get the
medical care that they need
well that that's exactly right they're
not getting the the care that they need
if you're a a woman who has a baby who
needs a NICU bed uh and the nearest bed
is not available in Yuma you have to go
100 miles to Phoenix uh that's a
terrible terrible impact on a new mother
on a newborn baby uh to get the help
they need you know it really does need
the attention of the White House and of
both parties not just Republicans who
were there on the scene but Democrats
who were absent yeah you hear this
migrant care cost being labeled as
unsustainable by that CEO how long
though Congress and be for medical care
in all 50 states is compromised because
resources are going to Illegal migrants
instead of citizens
yeah you just talk to people in my neck
the woods in Virginia where Troopers are
pulling over Vans full of migrants being
trafficked and drugs being trafficked in
our communities people dying from
fentanyl education systems Health Care
Systems being overloaded and that's
Virginia you talk about Yuma Arizona
it's unsustainable and uh we really do
need to take action now really quickly
before we let you go you were down at
the border you saw it you're in Arizona
right now you mentioned the wall would
the Wall prevent
a lot of this from happening 10 seconds
the wall would do a lot towards
preventing it from happening it would
funnel people toward Border Protection
and the keeping people in Arizona or in
Mexico while they await their Asylum
hearing that's the solution we need also
maybe Democrats showing up to one of
these hearings would be here that would
help as well Congressman Ben Klein thank
you for joining us thank you I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis